hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now guys i'm doing youtube
videos because i want to pass the
knowledge i want to explain to you guys
how actually protraders are working and
i want to show you
the different tools and techniques that
i use that work for me
that you can use to make money on the
market so if you want to know about all
the stuff and i'm sure you do
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
so guys first what happened on imc last
week i'm doing like uh
regularly some updates on the stock so
i'm on a daily time frame and you can
see that basically nothing happened guys
so where are our support levels so the
closest support level that we have
is actually the resistance that we broke
that was at 750 guys
to get this resistance i just connect
you know the recent highs that i had in
2020
so here here and i can see that here i
had some build up and then we broke it
we tested it we go higher i can show you
guys how this is working very quickly
but don't want to lose too much time
here so this is 7.50
we consolidate we break it we test we go
higher we test we go higher all right
so 750 is our closest support so if you
are not long the stock and you like the
stock
then it's a nice level to buy with a
stop loss i know that you guys
not gonna like what i say but guys we
trade with stop loss
if it breaks 750 then the next
throughput level
is 5 30 you know this whole area same
thing guys
because it was the previous resistance i
just connect this high and this high
this trend line and you can see that
here it acted very well as
support so our next support levels are
530
and 480. all right i'm going to come
back to the technicals but
first let's have a look at the news so
i like to check the short interest like
i told you guys you can find it on
marketbeat amc
now it's updated everywhere it's updated
every weeks
the correct number is 48 million shares
which is around 12 percent of the total
flood share
so big it's just 48 divided by 375. the
total public float is actually higher
than this because they emitted shares
guys during the rally they needed money
so they raised money through equity you
know this is a common thing to do when
your stock price is going higher
and they did it and the total number of
shares in bloomberg is 440 million
something like this
so it's correct bloomberg is not wrong
i'm not allowed to show
those guys to you here because this is
what i use for work and if i do it i
might lose my job
and i don't want to lose my job because
i want to keep updating you guys with
all this interesting data
so the real percentage of short shares
is
around eight nine percent but it's same
guys eight
nine twelve thirteen we don't care it's
not high so don't expect any short
squeeze but
what you can expect guys is a healthy
rally
which i think is gonna happen i'm
actually very bullish guys on all the
stuff
so i know we have the kobe crisis and if
the vaccines are not efficient
then maybe some entertainment companies
like imc will struggle a bit more to
recover but eventually they will
and the unlimited flow of money that we
can see in the economy right now
is creating a bubble and guys i think
we're at the beginning of the battle you
know
and i did some videos you guys need to
go check it out on the s p 500 and the
nasdaq and you're gonna be
pretty shocked to see my levels and the
reasons why i think we are just at the
beginning of the bubble
which is going to last i think one or
two years so i don't want to spoil you
guys but what i can tell you is that my
levels are insane
and i believe in that quite strongly now
to keep on
amc guys we have something very
interesting so i like to go on yahoo
finance or just that
amc and you can find the news so there
is nothing
very interesting like i said you know
it's mostly the vaccines that are going
to tell us if the entertainment
companies like ansi
are going to recover quickly or not but
you can find this
article guys so the social tracking does
etf
what it is but it isn't let's check it
out
so when you click on it you can see that
basically the asset manager vanek
which is a very big asset manager is
creating its etf
on march 4 so today guys and that
it is going to be like actually
containing all the hot stocks
you know they actually going to play on
you know all the
different indicators they can use to see
if a stock is hot on the social medias
on reddit and worcester beds on twitter
and they're going to include it in or
not if it's hot you know it's going to
be dynamic um
active management like we call it so
it's it's very
interesting guys and this is actually
showing me as well that you know we are
in a kind of bubble mode
you know when this stuff is happening
it's they're not picking stocks for the
fundamentals
they're picking them because people
talking about them you know so this is
but whatever it's the beginning of the
bubble and i would be a buyer of this
etf for sure
and you can see that they are using the
social medias perfectly this guy
dave putnoy who is actually a internet
celebrity
probably not this guy he's a shareholder
of this
new etf and he's making this a promotion
video which is very funny for me
and look what he is saying so
this thursday on the new york stock
exchange
there was a new etf launching an etf
that i'm hard that i'm putting my face
behind my reputation behind
everything so you see he is basically
promoting it
using his influence on the social medias
so very smart very good move uh those
guys
are right to associate with this guy
because it's going you know if they want
to target
guys like uh who hang out on reddit and
stuff like this they need
this kind of people to help them promote
their etf
you know finance is not on its own
anymore they need you know
all the other market participants that
we can find on reddit to actually
perform
what else is interesting i want you to
show you ddg nothing
i haven't called it happened all of a
sudden the amount of
chatter on the internet about stock
exploding so
as you can see you know he's basically
using the fact that everything is
exploding he's
showing us this volcano that is
exploding he's trying to use our
emotions to actually put our money
in this stuff so like i said very
interesting to follow guys i'm gonna
check it out as soon as it's listed
and as soon as we can have more
information about the stuff but let me
conclude
for the amc technicals so like i said
support level 750
next one 5 30 you know somewhere here
530
then 480 below 480 guys you know below
let's say 450
please be careful guys you need to
reconsider everything this means that
you know something has not worked out
as it should it means that we have new
information that has been analyzed by
the market
and that you need to take it into
account in your trades and maybe
wait a bit before putting more money
into this stock
in terms of target like i said guys i
expect you know the most
natural target is actually 35
because this is the highest level around
here doesn't mean we won't go higher
maybe we will you know i'm not saying we
won't
i'm just saying that it's a nice target
all right which is like
actually 300 lower right
so it's a nice target and it's
interesting to notice
that you can find this target in a
different way you can use fib extensions
i use it every day it's working very
well
it's only using basically the golden
number ratio and it's applying it to
last move so you measure the last
big move you know uh easy to do so here
the last big move is from here to here
obviously then corrected
you measure this and you apply it to the
bottom of the new
wave and this oh funny thing guys the
1.618 which is the most likely
ratio to be reached for the next wave is
actually 35. oh
funny 35 the highest level as i just
showed you when you have a double signal
like this it makes it more likely to
happen
you know and this kind of stuff as i
always say it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy is if everybody
is seeing things like me and i think you
know
a lot of people use the same tools as i
do because they are working
so then it makes them you know buyers
until 35 and then they're going to take
profits here
so if you loan the staff you can take
some profits at 35. i know you don't
like it i know you guys
like the stocks and you don't want to
take profits but you know
this is how we make money actually on
the market if you know you have
something like this
then all right you know here you take
profits here then you can
play the retracement from here to here
to play the retracement you use feed
retracement i will show you guys how it
works if we reach this level
and then you need to wait for breakout
you don't buy the breakout you buy the
re-test
so you know you basically take profits
here
reload against around this levels then
retake your profits here
and then reload around these levels you
don't buy the breakouts you wait for the
retest there is always a retest look
here
how many people bought here and got
destroyed here
a lot a lot and who is selling here
professionals who is buying here
everybody so what i mean is that guys
we have a lot of stocks i'm gonna
analyze a lot of them we have a lot of
opportunities
don't rush don't buy at stupid levels
buy at good levels
all right guys that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i see you guys